[Music]
footwork is the body gagging up with
music they both go ahead and hand
[Music]
footwork the energy-packed high speed
and mesmerizing dance born on the south
and west side of Chicago and the music
that drives the move from this movement
third in the 90s this man was there I am
are people but I am considered the
Godfather of Chicago footwork music I am
a DJ as well as a producer the niche
movement has grown worldwide is probably
the producers is tired of Korea London
but it might have not started if it
wasn't for dancers and DJs who wanted to
speed things up the - Cruise was having
a dance competition the track that was
being played it was a normal record they
were making going faster they actually a
routine - that they wanted competition
and when the music setup started - then
we started off at 1:45 these prevented I
watch them grow for 145 to 160
the base building the footwear track is
base kick snare drum kick hi-hat plus
what sounds when you go to use if you go
to use the south banking on King Drive
banking on King Drive banking on King
drop baguette don't change try banking
on King try [ __ ] on King Don King drop
the music will sound as close to hip-hop
due to the samples the groove is
something that's totally that's what
separates it to become footwork but
without dancers for the fast-paced music
footwork wouldn't be footwork you go
side to side front to back kick your
feet up hard then whatever moves you
could do before your feet hit the floor
the dance is style carefully it looks
something but it does become hard once
you try to beat on between it before as
this second generation is trying to
master the art of footwork its building
a positive global community of dancers
and DJ the impact that the people in
Chicago help push out other people and
they say here we love it just as much as
you do of this love with every moment
you
[Music]